♪ ♪
[CROWD CHANTING]
>> Laura: THAT WAS THE SCENE
AS A LONG-TIME TRAP ASSOCIATE
ROGER STONE LEFT HIS ARRAIGNMENT
THIS AFTERNOON.
HE PLED NOT GUILTY TO CHARGES
STEMMING FROM THE MUELLER PROBE
FOR AGES FIVE DAYS INTO HIS HOME
WAS WARMED BY DOZENS OF FBI
AGENTS IN A PRE-DAWN RAID.
NOW IN HIS FIRST TELEVISION
INTERVIEW SINCE BEING A RAND,
ROGER STONE JOINS US LIVE.
ROGER, YOU HAVE NOT HAD A BUSY
FEW DAYS TO SAY THE LEAST.
ON SUNDAY YOU TOLD GEORGE
STEPHANOPOULOS THAT HE WOULD BE
OPEN, PERHAPS, TO COOPERATING
WITH MUELLER.
BUT JUST YESTERDAY YOU SEEMED TO
CHANGE YOUR TUNE.
WHAT IS GOING ON?
WHICH IS IT?
>> I THINK MY COMMENTS ON ABC
MAY HAVE BEEN MISCONSTRUED.
WHAT I MEANT WAS, I'M NOT GOING
TO BEAR FALSE WITNESS AGAINST
ANYBODY.
I'M GOING TO TELL THE TRUTH
UNDER OATH AND TO THE
INVESTIGATORS IF THEY HAVE
QUESTIONS.
SUBJECT, OBVIOUSLY, TO THE
ADVICE FORMATWISE OF MY
ATTORNEYS.
BUT I'M NOT GOING TO DO WHAT
MICHAEL COHEN HAS DONE.
I'M NOT GOING TO MAKE UP LIES OR
BEAR FALSE WITNESS AGAINST
DONALD TRUMP OR ANYONE ELSE.
THE TRUTH OF THE MATTER IS, EVEN
THOUGH I'M ACCUSED OF LYING,
WHEN I GET ADAM SCHIFF ON THE
STAND, WHEN I GET ERIC SWALWELL
ALMOST END, WHEN I GET OTHER
MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE ON THE
STAND, I WILL DEMONSTRATE THEY
ARE THE ONES THAT ARE LYING,
NOT ME.
>> Laura: YOUR OLD PAL JEROME
CORSI WAS ON WITH
MARTHA MacCALLUM EARLIER
TONIGHT AND HAD A WARNING FOR
YOU.
WATCH.
>> THEY ARE EXTREMELY THOROUGH.
THEY HAVE EVERYTHING.
ROGER SHOULDN'T UNDERESTIMATE
THAT EVERY COMMUNICATION HE HAD
BECOME A TELEPHONE, EMAIL, WHO
HE MET WITH IN PERSON, THE
MUELLER TEAM HAS SPENT ENORMOUS,
ENDLESS RESOURCES, SO ROGER
SHOULD GO INTO THIS FULLY
PREPARED UNDERSTANDING THAT HE
IS NOT GOING TO BE ABLE TO DODGE
THE EVIDENCE THAT I AM SURE
MUELLER HAS.
>> Laura: YOUR REACTION TO
THAT?
>> UNFORTUNATELY, DR. JEROME
CORSI HAS ALREADY SAID A COUPLE
OF THINGS ABOUT ME THAT ARE
DEMONSTRABLY NOT TRUE.
>> Laura: LIKE WHAT?
>> FOR EXAMPLE, A MEMBER WHO
BROUGHT ME REGARDING THE PODESTA
BROTHERS' LUCRATIVE BUSINESS
DEALINGS IN RUSSIA BASED ON
PUBLIC REPORTS PUBLISHED BY
PETER SCHWEIZER, AND
"THE NEW YORK POST" DAN
BREITBART, SOMEHOW A COVER STORY
BREITBART, SOMEHOW A COVER STOR,
BREITBART, SOMEHOW A COVER STORA
BREITBART, SOMEHOW A COVER STORC
BREITBART, SOMEHOW A COVER STORV
BREITBART, SOMEHOW A COVER STORR
BREITBART, SOMEHOW A COVER STORS
BREITBART, SOMEHOW A COVER STORO
BREITBART, SOMEHOW A COVER STORY
BREITBART, SOMEHOW A COVER STORF
BREITBART, SOMEHOW A COVER STORR
WHAT?
WHAT WOULD THERE BE TO COVER UP?
MY TWEET, THE PODESTA BROTHERS,
WAS NONCONTROVERSIAL FOR SIX
WEEKS.
DR. JEROME CORSI SAID HE TOLD ME
THAT HE TOLD ME THAT
JOHN PODESTA'S EMAILS HAD BEEN
STOLEN.
ON TUCKER CARLSON, HE SAID HE
TOLD MANY PEOPLE THAT PRAYED
WITH ARI MALABAR, NOT REALLY A
JOURNALIST, HE SAYS HE TOLD
EVERYBODY THAT.
HE NEVER TOLD ME THAT, AND MAYBE
HE DIDN'T TELL US WHO ELSE HE
TOLD.
HE ALSO SAID THAT I KNEW ABOUT
THE BILLY BUSH NBC TAPE AND I
DIRECTED HIM TO CONTACT
JULIAN ASSANGE AND TELL HIM TO
MOVE UP OR CHANGE THE NUMBER OF
DATA TO DISTRACT FROM THAT.
WHOLE CLOTH.
UNFORTUNATELY FOR DR. CORSI, I
HAVE TEXT MESSAGES AND EMAILS
AND METADATA THAT SHOWS THAT
HE'S NOT TELLING THE TRUTH.
>> Laura: I KNOW YOU HAVE
ALREADY SAID THAT YOU HAVE NOT
DELETED ANY EMAILS FROM ANY
EMAIL ADDRESS --
>> THAT IS CORRECT.
>> Laura: ANY PHYSICAL
DOCUMENTS, HAVE THEY EVER BEEN
DESTROYED BY YOU?
>> NO, ABSOLUTELY NOT.
NOW IT IS TRUE THAT I FORGOT
THAT I HAD TEXT MESSAGES IN AN
OLD CELL PHONE THAT ARE ENTIRELY
EXCULPATORY, WHICH PROVE
DEFINITIVELY THAT RANDY CREDITO
WAS MY SOURCE AS TO THE
CONTENT --
>> Laura: IS THAT ONE OF THE
FALSE STATEMENTS THAT YOU MADE?
>> YES.
THAT WOULD BE ONE OF THE FALSE
STATEMENTS.
BUT THE TEXT MESSAGES PROVE THAT
HE WAS MY SOURCE AS TO THE
SIGNIFICANCE IN THE OCTOBER
RELEASE DATE OF THE WIKILEAKS.
>> Laura: WE TALKED ABOUT THAT
ON RADIO AS WELL AT THE TIME.
WE ALL FORGET THINGS.
BUT THESE ARE PRETTY -- GIVEN
THE NATURE OF THIS
INVESTIGATION, MIGHT YOU HAVE
FORGOTTEN OTHER THINGS?
>> TO THE EXTENT THAT I MADE
MISTAKES OF MEMORY, THEY WOULD
BE WITHOUT INTENT, AND IT WOULD
BE INCONSEQUENTIAL.
THEY WOULD NOT BE MATERIAL UNDER
THE LAW.
FOR ANY LEGAL EXPERT TO LOOK AT
THESE LITTLE EXCERPTS WITHOUT
READING FOUR AND A HALF HOURS OF
TESTIMONY TO SEE THE CONTEXT,
THE QUESTIONS BEFORE AND THE
QUESTIONS AFTER, WOULD BE
IRRESPONSIBLE.
BUT YOU CAN WATCH CNN AND SEE
THE INDICTMENT IS A SLAM DUNK.
MY ATTORNEYS DON'T THINK SO.
>> Laura: A FORMER FBI
ASSISTANT DIRECTOR WAS TALKING
ABOUT YOUR ONLY HOPE NOW BEING A
PARDON.
LET'S WATCH.
>> I'M A STRONG ADVOCATE OF THE
THEORY THAT STONE IS POSITIONING
HIMSELF FOR A PARDON AND THAT
IT'S LIKELY THE ONLY HOPE HE
HAS.
HE SEEMS DRIVEN AND MOTIVATED
MERELY BY ABSOLUTE PUBLICITY,
ABSOLUTE LEAPING IN THE CENTER
OF THINGS, REGARDLESS OF WHETHER
IT IS BAD PUBLICITY OR GOOD
PUBLICITY.
HE NEEDS TO BE THERE AND HE
SEEMS TO BE SHADED TOWARD THE
NEGATIVE.
>> Laura: IS THAT AT?
YOUR ONLY PATH OUTCOME ACCORDING
TO THESE CHARACTERS ON TV?
YOU'RE APPEARING TO TALK TO THE
PRESIDENT THROUGH OUR SHOW TO
GET A PARDON?
>> I DON'T KNOW MANY FBI AGENTS
WHO KNOW MUCH ABOUT POLITICIANS,
PUBLIC RELATIONS, OR THE LAW.
THE TRUTH OF THE MATTER IS, IF
YOU READ MY BOOK, "DON'T'S
RULES," I BELIEVE WHEN YOU'RE
FALSELY ACCUSED OF
SOMETHING, YOU SAY NOTHING, NO
COMMENT, OR ROGER STONE WAS
UNAVAILABLE, MOST AMERICANS
ASSUME YOU ARE GUILTY.
THE WHOLE PURPOSE OF THIS OVER
THE TOP RAID ON MY HOUSE, IN
WHICH THEY SENT IN MORE MEN THEN
WERE USED TO PROTECT OUR
COMPOUND IN BENGHAZI, WAS TO
PAINT A PICTURE OF ME COMING TO
POISON A JURY --
>> Laura: SO RIDICULOUS.
>> PUBLIC ENEMY NUMBER ONE.
>> Laura: ONE OF THE MORE
RIDICULOUS THINGS.
IT WAS OFF AND SEPARATE WAS
OFFENSIVE TO ME.
REGARDLESS OF WHAT GOES DOWN
HERE, THAT -- IT WAS LIKE ELLIE
AND GONZALES TIMES 29 OR TIMES
28.
IT WAS ABSURD.
WE ALSO HAD YOUR FRIEND OVER AT
MSNBC, MIKA BRZEZINSKI, WHO WAS
MAKING A POINT ABOUT YOUR CLAIM
THAT YOUR DOG WAS TERRORIZED.
HOW MANY DOGS DO HAVE THEM BY
THE WAY?
>> HAVE TWO DOGS.
>> Laura: WHAT KIND?
TO GO YORKSHIRE TERRIERS.
>> Laura: YORKIES.
THEY GET TERRORIZED EASILY.
I LOVE THEM BUT THEY ARE YOU
HAPPY.
HERE'S WHAT SHE SAID.
>> STONE'S COMPLAINT THAT HIS
DOGS WERE TERRORIZED IS ALSO A
TINY BUT IRONIC BECAUSE HIS
SEVEN COUNT INDICTMENT INCLUDES
THE ALLEGATION THAT STONE TRY TO
INTIMIDATE SOMEBODY BY
THREATENING THEIR THERAPY DOG.
DON'T DO THAT.
>> Laura: OKAY.
>> NUMBER ONE, RANDY CREDICO'S
DOG IS NOT REGISTERED IN
NEW YORK AS A THERAPY DOG.
NUMBER TWO, HE WASN'T FEEDING
THE DOG BECAUSE HE WAS SPENDING
HIS MONEY ON OTHER THINGS, AND
THAT WAS THE CONTEXT.
ONCE AGAIN, YOU TAKE SOMETHING
OUT OF CONTEXT, AND IT HAS A
DIFFERENT MEANING.
YOU CAN GO TO "THE DAILY CALLER"
AND READ THE ARTICLES I HAVE
WRITTEN ABOUT ANIMAL WELFARE AND
ENDING THE INHUMANE MEDICAL
TESTING ON DOGS AND CATS.
>> Laura: YEAH, I KNOW THIS
ABOUT ROGER, ROGER IS A VERY
PRO-ANIMAL PERSON LIKE I AM.
YOU CAN SAY IT DIRTY STRICT
COMIC TRICKSTER -- WHAT YOU'D DO
THE NIXING        RICHARD NIXONP
THE NIXING        RICHARD NIXONS
THE NIXING        RICHARD NIXONG
THE NIXING        RICHARD NIXONN
THE NIXING        RICHARD NIXONF
THE NIXING        RICHARD NIXONR
EVERY APPEARANCE?
>> WHEN I WAS ARRESTED, I WAS
WEARING MY "ROGER STONE DID
NOTHING WRONG" T-SHIRT.
YOU CAN BUY THEM AT 1776 DOT
JOB.
>> Laura: BY THE WAY, POMPEO
SAYS THAT WIKILEAKS IS A
NONSTATE HOSTILE INTELLIGENCE
SERVICE.
WHY WOULD YOU WORK WITH THEM?
>> COULD I SEE THE PROOF OF
THAT, PLEASE?
WHERE IS THAT A JUDICIAL
DECISION THAT SAYS THAT?
I'M AFRAID OUR INTELLIGENCE
SERVICES HAVE BEEN POLITICIZED.
JOHN BRENNAN SAYS THE SAME
THING.
I DON'T BELIEVE IT TO BE TRUE.
SO IT'S A CLAIM.
IT'S NEVER BEEN PROVED IT A U.S.
COURT OF LAW.
>> Laura: TALKING ABOUT ROGER
HAVING GOTTEN --
>> WE DON'T KNOW THAT PRAYED
>> Laura: EVERYONE CONCLUDED
BUT THEY PRONOUNCE IT.
>> IS A TALKING POINT.
IT'S UNPROVEN IN A COURT OF LAW
AND I DON'T THINK IT'S TRUE.
JULIAN ASSANGE WAS INTERVIEWED
BY SEAN HANNITY, AND HE'S A
JOURNALIST.
HE DOES A SAME THING OF
"THE NEW YORK TIMES" AND
"THE WASHINGTON POST" AND
"THE WALL STREET JOURNAL" DO
POINT >> Laura: ROGER,
WE'LL BE WATCHING.
WHEN IS YOUR NEXT APPEARANCE?
>> I ACTUALLY WILL COME ON WITH